one of the things that did occur you
mentioned a Silicon Valley Bank there
there was a big bump in terms of Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies around about
that time and it seemed like one of the
first periods where people genuinely saw
crypto as a store of value as a way to
just I I need to put my money somewhere
that I feel is safe and given the last
18 months of what's happened with crypto
considering that as that's the place I'm
going to store my Assets in order for it
to be safe I think said quite a lot
about how people sort of perceived the
state of the dollar and the security of
Banks and stuff at the moment
what what's the role of Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency in a the current economy
in your in your eyes
um I think
um
cryptocurrency or Bitcoin
um doesn't move in a reliable way
related to
almost anything it uh you know moves up
and down because of
um this mood and that move and mood
um and um unlike gold let's say I I
would prefer gold than and I would
prefer crypto for various reasons crypto
um
it it's very easy to track the owners
and transactions in it it's not liked by
the government
um it's
um
it doesn't move in a way that's
consistent with you know kind of any of
the environments and it's a fairly and
it's a small asset class
um you know we talk a lot more about it
but its size is about you know 30
percent of the size of Microsoft and
Microsoft is one stock among many stocks
so uh it's given uh probably a lot more
attention
um I don't know uh you know who who
knows maybe you know there's some
element of it I don't understand why
people are more inclined to go to
bitcoin than gold
um if you look internationally
um gold is uh for central banks the
third highest Reserve asset first is
dollars then Euros then gold then uh
Japanese Yen
um and Central Bankers are buying gold
and they're not buying
um bonds and um and so and it's you know
Timeless and Universal it's been there
so um but
um you know
um so I'm not
I'm not a big
fan of it as I've said before
um you know having a little bit I have a
little bit of it but if you have a
little bit of it you have to
um think about those things and you know
like I said you know you have to be
prepared for it to fall a lot you know
if if it goes down 80 or something but
that limits the amount that you can have
in it so I don't know it's um I don't
think a lot of Bitcoin I think what's
interesting there is
holding crypto essentially has a
cognitive load on you
using it as somewhere that you're using
for investment as a store of value to
just put assets that you've got
it's almost there is a price that you
pay because of the volatility but the
price that you pay is with your own
sanity
with regards to that
um which is something that I hadn't
quite considered there are uh less
sanity sapping uh forms of investment
yeah that's a that's a good way to do
you know what I mean
I've seen
so many people you know I've seen people
get very rich and I've seen get people
get very broke with it I have friends in
both camps yeah
so you know we've spoken about today
this very quickly changing highly
volatile environment that we're in
whether that be socio-culturally
politically globally locally
financially
where should people go
in order to find
um some solace in this given the fact
that it is difficult it's difficult to
exist in this world
um
go to
go to places or spend time
where there's not as much of this junk
going on you know
um
I mean first of all I think recognize
let's let's go to some of the basics
[Music]
um
what do you really need
um you know you need a bed to sleep in
you need food to eat
um
um most
depressions most people remain employed
most wars most people don't get die or
get in injured
[Music]
um
uh so
um you know let's put let's calm down
and put all this in place bit let's be
in places where there's
um
you know goodness and Harmony and Beauty
you know maybe spend more time in nature
or you know you go out there and
um I'd like to meditate meditate is
meditation has had a big effect on me so
um yeah
um
don't get all stressed about it you know
navigate it well
um and you know enjoy life enjoy those
things and I think that that's
you know that I think that's most
important what would you say to the
people that say how am I expected to
enjoy life when there's all of this
chaos going on there's so many bad news
stories and headlines and what about the
financial collapse
well um
first of all
if it's really having that impact on you
don't get so hung up on the financial
stories and you don't don't watch the
television or something you know go out
for a nice walk and
in the nature like all that story you
don't really need all that story Okay
now what's going to happen to you like I
say
um you know don't get so hung up on
expectations of having the most amount
of money or whatever just you know think
about it
um like I say where will you lose where
you live will you you know
what matters you know uh your friends
your family your
um you know give a bed to a good bed to
sleep in for adequate food right out
into nature you know like uh my own view
is sometimes you know like the most
luxurious thing I can do is take a tent
and be out in a beautiful spot you know
um so
um
you know
avoid it
um you know no don't get stressed out
you know understand it be prepared
redefining success and what happiness
means and what we should be aiming for
in life I think is a a very worthwhile
Pursuit right I'll tell you
um
this idea of success being
measured in the amount of money and
status you have is really screwed up
um
like if you think about money
and and this is uh com shown in measures
of happiness
past the basic amount of money so that
you don't have uh the misery there is no
correlation between the level of money
you have and the level of happiness you
have
lots of studies show that and the
highest correlation
is do you have a community and that's
the highest source of
um
happiness and also it longevity it has a
big effect on longevities stress and
smoking more than stopping alcohol more
than going to the gym and exercising
right right
and so uh and then you think like what
is money for it has no intrinsic value
it only has a value of what it buys and
so
um it has a limited marginal ability you
benefit you you add more and more to it
and you know like what are you gonna do
okay so you're going to get a bigger
house or a bigger car or what you know
okay
um and what does that really mean
incrementally relative to spending time
with friends and family and all of those
things you know most of the good things
in life are not expensive right
um friends family uh nature sex anything
you know it's not going to get better
with more money right it's really better
and so
um it seems to me that
um it then can become an obsession
um and that's not healthy
so
I think it's you know by and large you
handle it well and it's all going to be
okay
um it's all gonna be okay what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]